MMM.
Hello and welcome to the third lesson
in native laying dotcoms course on
historical linguistics
and language change.
This time around using the concepts
that you learned in the last lesson,
namely cognates,
which are inherited words,
borrowings and chance.
I want you to take a look for a minute
at some basic core words from four
languages. These languages
are Italian, Galician,
Portuguese,
and Mallory.
These words are actually
fairly representative of
the relationships between
these languages.
Take a moment to consider which
languages share a common ancestry and how
closely these languages must be related.
Wow.
We have good grounds for considering
that Portuguese and Galician are very
closely related. We also have
grounds for saying that Italian,
Portuguese and coalition
are less closely related,
but they're all related to each other.
As long as we grouped Galician in
Portuguese more closely together in this
relationship,
we can say that Italian,
Galician and Portuguese are
all related to each other.
Now are you on the other hand?
Doesn't seem to be related at all,
so at this point we'll set it to the
side and say that it's an unrelated
language. That is, it may be
related to other languages,
but it is not related to Italian Galician
in Portuguese at least as far as we
can tell this set of words,
but that's not enough at this point.
We just have a flat understanding
of the relationships.
We should extend this back the
same way we do with a family tree.
Now what we'll do is we'll group Galician
in Portuguese together in one branch
of the tree and then Italian in
a separate branch of the tree,
so now we've extended this
relationship back over time.
The branches that extend upwards on this
diagram show you that in the past these
languages were actually more closely
related to each other. In other words,
they diverge from common ancestors.
In the case of Galician in Portuguese,
they actually diverged from a
nearer common ancestor. Right?
You see that note?
This note here is the common ancestor
of both collision and Portuguese.
No, this no tears. Also
related to Italian.
There's an even further note
meaning further back in time.
That is the common ancestor of
Italian Galician in Portuguese.
Now we have two question marks here.
What do these question marks mean?
They're just notes on our diagram,
but they more than that,
there's actually some language spoken
in the past that must be the common
ancestor of both Galician and Portuguese.
Otherwise they wouldn't be around.
They wouldn't share these common cognates,
so these common cognates derived
from words in a single language,
this single ancestor language.
Now there's an even more remote
common ancestor from Galician,
Portuguese and Italian,
and that's a form of vulgar
Latin in at least some small way.
These two languages, Galician,
Portuguese and vulgar Latin are a tested.
That means we have documents
we can look back at.
We can look today at documents that
were written in those languages.
We have some attestation of their
existence. We know what they look like.
We can see their vocabulary items and
written words and based on other evidence,
we actually have some knowledge of
how those words were pronounced.
These were real languages
that are documented.
What happens when we don't
have that kind of attestation?
We'll have to get a little
bit more innovative.
We'll have to use something known as
reconstruction to posit a hypothetical
ancestor language.
That's the parent of the modern languages.
In our next lesson,
we'll look at how exactly we do that,
and we'll go about doing two basic
reconstructions to help you get an
understanding for the process of
how we would look back in time,
how we would reconstruct
an ancestor language.
I hope you'll join me as we do that and
gain some more perspective on historical
linguistics.